hi everyone its Jonah here some of you
have requested for a full vegan meal
plan and that is what I'm going to show
you today remember with all my meal
plans as long as you get the foundation
right you can always mix and match your
own ingredients okay so the foundation
is it has to be clean food fresh food no
processed food no junk food and no
pre-packed food and in most of your
meals you should aim for a healthy
balance of protein carbs healthy fats
and vegetables or fruits remember to
count your calories and consume the
right amount of calories in order for
you to lose weight all to maintain your
weight I would always encourage you to
eat every three to four hours to avoid
hunger drink at least 3 liters of water
a day do workout because it helps in
your weight loss process and it has a
lot of health benefits as well and for
all my Marist you can always grab them
in box store that in the fridge and have
that the next day therefore its stress
free it's really healthy with simple
everyday ingredients so let's start with
breakfast your breakfast is going to be
boat meal topped with your favorite
fruit the ingredients you need are 40
gram of a cook oatmeal 200 ml of our
milk and about 100 gram of your favorite
fruit I have chose
today could be 40 gram of oats with the
200 ml of milk okay under slogans this
should take you about 15 minutes to cook
and you should stir it constantly so
once you're always I could take it out
and what you want to do is just chop
your strawberries into your oats so
there you go that's your breakfast whole
milk top with your favorite fruits
really simple quick and full of
nutrition all this should really be
encouraged to have more oatmeal because
of the fiber content it's full of
protein it helps to lower cholesterol
level it's good for your digestion and
also it's good for your skin and all for
almond milk it actually contains half
the calories compared to your ordinary
milk and this whole ball contains only
231 calories plus you are getting your
two a day from your fruits already so as
you know I always like my green tea in
the morning so that's my vegan breakfast
for today it's mid-morning and it's a
second meal of the day
for those of you who have sweet tooth
and you've been looking for healthier
options to fulfill your sweet tooth you
will love my next recipe I'm going to
show you how to make a no-bake peanut
butter energy bar it's really simple it
takes you less than five minutes to prep
this bar is high in protein which is
important for vegan to have and is sweet
at the same time so the ingredients you
need are 113 point 5 gram of smooth
peanut butter
170 grams of honey I know that's not
vegan if you're a vegan go for maple
syrup in fact they are lower in calories
in comparison to honey 81 grams of dry
on cook oatmeal and about 15 grams of
makes nuts seeds or any dry fruits that
you like for my recipe I've used mix
since so what you want to do is to mix
your peanut butter up with your honey or
maple syrup and just get it up in a
non-sticky pan and a slow heat okay and
just stir it until it's all nicely mixed
once it's mixed it should be quite quick
what you want to do is just to put your
oats in it and just mix it up make sure
it's all nicely covered and mix
and lastly you can sprinkle your nuts or
any dried fruit or any seeds I've chosen
seeds so just sprinkle mix it up and
again just mix it all up so once it's
all nicely mixed what you want to do is
just to transfer it into a square tin
just put it all in and press it down so
once they're all nice and neat what you
want to do now is to chill it in the
fridge for 30 minutes and it's ready so
here's my sweet tooth alternative peanut
butter oats energy bar each block
contains about 183 calories peanut
butter is high in calories but they are
packed full of healthy fat and protein
it contains 28% of protein therefore
consume them in moderation and you're
getting your sweetness from the natural
honey or natural maple syrup so remember
to consume each bar in moderation have
one bar as a mid-morning snack and store
the rest in the fridge and having the
next day it should last you up to 5 days
in the fridge so but for lunch I'm going
to show you how to make a huge plate of
creamy salad that is packed with protein
if you like coleslaw you will like this
the ingredients you need are 40 gram of
quinoa uncooked which will be about 100
grams of cooked quinoa chickpeas 120
grams of dried chickpeas tomatoes or any
other vegetables about 200 gram and soil
yogurts about 100
of soil yogurt so cook your quinoa with
about 200ml of water and leave it for
about 15 to 18 minutes for it to cook
okay so the quinoa is cooked I've heated
up my chickpeas I've sliced my tomatoes
and so what I'm going to do now is to
mix the quinoa with the chickpeas
together with the soil yoghurt this is
your creamy protein pack lunch the
quinoa is providing you with 13% of
protein chickpeas great source of
protein
23% of protein and the tomatoes are
providing you your tube attain and this
home plate only contains 374 calories
remember you can pack it and prepare it
for hand story in the fridge and it's
great if it isn't chilled so bring it to
school next day or bring it to one next
day so it's the fourth meal of the day
and you should have already drank about
2 liters of water I plan to work out in
the next hour what I'm going to show you
now is how to make my pre-workout drink
or smoothie this will provide you with
lots of energy and they were really
pumped to your workout the ingredients
you need are 100 gram of frozen and
sliced bananas 1 shot of black coffee
which is about 60 and help and 200 ml of
milk
like any smoothing all you need to do is
mix all the ingredients up and plan it
and it can be done in two minutes so
this is my pre-workout drink the
caffeine in it would really boosts your
metabolism
it would increase your heart rate when
you're working out which will help you
to burn more fat the banana contains
COTS carbs is needed to provide you with
the energy you need when you're working
out so this whole glass only contains
137 calories it will really give you the
energy you need for a good quality
workout if you don't like happen you can
always take it out of the ingredient
it's dinner time is your last meal of
the day and if you've just completed
your gym you want something big to fill
you up at the same time it's not too
high in calories so I'm going to show
you how to make a very lightly stir fry
mix vegetables with tofu and took a
company it is your small bowl of brown
rice if you are Chinese you know that
this dish is very commonly cooked and it
is very healthy the ingredients you need
are half a block of tofu that's about
175 grow mixed vegetables whatever
vegetables you want and
be unlimited I've chosen broccoli
carrots and sweet corn for mine and that
amount weighs about 200 gram hoisin
sauce
- poison sauce but hoisin sauce is very
commonly used as well 1 tablespoon and
40 gram of uncooked brown rice when it's
cooked it will be about 100 gram we're
going to let you stir fry it with 1
teaspoon of oil if you're looking to cap
on your calories you don't even have to
use any quality oil I'm going to mix my
vegetable first because it takes longer
to cook especially my carrots before I
add my tofu I'm just going to let it
simmer as you can see it's really a last
bit of food so losing weight doesn't
mean starving so once the carrots and
the broccoli is a slightly softer just
add the tofu
sleep is one tablespoon of hoisin sauce
or oyster sauce or flavor so just
drizzle it around okay just gently very
gently stir it because you do not want
your tribute to be in pieces and let it
simmer for a while it's smelling really
good right now and it's a huge portion I
don't think I can finish it on my own
and this whole meal only contains 411
calories same thing it's really
important to have protein in your meals
this tofu is actually providing you with
16% of protein why do we go for brown
rice is because of the nutrients in it
and it's also providing you with 2.5% of
protein I know that most families prefer
white rice and it's fine to consume
white rice as long as it is in
moderation so try this out let me know
anything it's a huge portion same thing
you can always prep it beforehand story
in the fridge and all you need to do is
to warming up the next day it is now the
end of the day you should already have
consumed 5 small meals drink 3 liters of
water you have thoughts of activities
and the entire meal plan
for you is just right above 1300
calories
remember adjust the calories according
to your goal and as vegans or
vegetarians it is very important to pack
proteins into your meal all these
ingredients I've chosen today are packed
with protein you don't have to follow my
recipes I'm sure you are more creative
than I am
just remember the foundation of the
milkman is according to the calories you
need and trust me you will be losing
weight it is 80% nutrition and 20%
exercise don't forget to like this video
share this video please do subscribe to
my youtube channel for more nutritional
and fitness videos and please do check
my Facebook out for more daily tips
you